hello we're glad you've joined us for
this webinar comprehensive proteomics
and lipid omics strategies to advance
disparities research and Alchemist
disease i am michelle ashton of laborat
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's and brought to you
by Agilent to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor
[Music]
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask
questions and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by typing it into the ask a
question box this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits and present today's speaker
may robinson the associate professor of
chemistry at vanderbilt university to
learn more about our speaker please
click on the speaker tab found at the
top of your screen
renee you may now begin your
presentation
hi thank you for the opportunity
to present today the title of my talk is
comprehensive proteomics and lipid omec
strategies to advance disparities
research and Alzheimer's disease and so
what I hope to do is give you an idea of
some of the kinds of research that are
taking place in our laboratory right now
that are not fully complete but are
still ongoing projects so to get started
I thought it would be interesting to
look at what the aging demographic looks
like worldwide and if you look at data
from 2017 and what you see that on
average across most countries one ate
people over the age of six are over the
age of sixty I'm in 2017 and when you
look at the lower graph it shows you the
distribution of what that looks like
across different countries and you can
see that North America and a lot of
Europe and Australia have a high
population of Oda individuals however
what's predicted to happen by 2050 is
that one in five individuals will be
over the age of 60 so this is the next
30 years and you can see how this
demographic would ship across the world
and that there would be more individuals
that are going to fall into this oder
demographic and this becomes interesting
to think about and of course of studying
disease because there are a number of
diseases where age is the biggest risk
factor and so here I'm showing you data
from the u.s. from 2016 and 2017 and
what you can see here is the United
States heart disease and cancer are the
tattoo killers of individuals however
there are a number of other different
kinds of diseases such as stroke
diabetes kidney disease and Alzheimer's
disease to also make into this top 10
list of causes of death and so for our
group we've been really interested in
looking at Alzheimer's disease and so
you can see here that it's the sixth
leading cause of death in the United
States and what we find interesting in
terms of statistics about Alzheimer's
disease is the fact that while diseases
such as heart disease the therapies in
the
treatments for these have decreased the
number of deaths that have occurred over
time the number of deaths that occur
from Alzheimer's disease have steadily
been increasing over the time when you
look at data over the last 15 years ago
and so currently there is no cure or
effective treatment for Alzheimer's
disease that can stop delay or slow the
progression of disease and so there's
really a lot of work that needs to be
done in order to reduce the number of
people that are suffering from this
particular disease what we also find
interesting about Alzheimer's disease
within on the united states is the fact
that there are racial and ethnic
disparities that exist when you look at
the prevalence of disease and so for
example I'm here I'm showing you data
for the prevalence of Alzheimer's
disease and african-americans compared
to non-hispanic whites which is the
purple trace and what you see is that as
aging increase there's a larger gap
between these two different ethnic
groups in terms of prevalence of 18 so
African Americans are 2 to 3 times more
likely to have Alzheimer's disease than
Caucasians or non-hispanic white
individuals Hispanic individuals in the
US are one and a half to two times more
likely and so you can see that even
though African Americans make up a small
percentage of the u.s. demographic that
they make up a large percentage of
individuals that will be suffering from
this disease moving for what's also
interesting is the costs that are
associated with Alzheimer's disease care
and caregiving cost and you can see that
a small percentage of the population
that is comprised by African Americans
represents one-third of the total cost
that I spent on Alzheimer's disease and
other dementias and so this presents a
lot of socio-economic and demographic
issues in the United States we're trying
to figure out how to reduce these
disparities for this and for other group
so we started to think about what some
of the contributions are for this
particular disparities and so if you
look at this chart and what you see that
what you see on the left is that there
are different kinds of comorbidity so
things like heart disease that we
mentioned prior high cholesterol
hypertension obesity and strokes that
contribute to Alzheimer's disease
pathogenesis so these are all risk
factors for AD in addition to aging and
then there's certain genes such as I'm a
Bowie for which you've heard a lot about
and other genes like after seven and
throw one which end up being potential
genetic risk factors for
african-americans with Alzheimer's
disease and so these different
comorbidities and genetic factors can
directly impact pathological hallmarks
and Alzheimer's disease including things
like Emily beta deposition and oxidative
stress and then ultimately to
Alzheimer's disease however at this
point there's not a clear understanding
of what the complete molecular basis is
for these racial disparities that exist
within Alzheimer's disease when one
looks at the relationship between what
happens inside of the brain and outside
of the brain and Alzheimer's disease I
wanted to bring to your attention a few
things that we and others have observed
so this is coming from work by trunk on
and all who are demonstrating here in
this chart that the brain isn't the only
place where Emily molecules exist but
also the potential exists in the heart
and that these molecules can be
trafficked between the brain and the
heart and so this can work both ways
where these deposits can impact
Emily bata in the brain and influence
Alzheimer's disease pathology but also
having these amyloid deposits in the
heart can impact heart function and so
this lends some idea to the salt of
whether or not Alzheimer's disease is a
systemic issue and just a for the hoenn
on this point these are data that come
from
same study that essentially show you
over here that the levels of Emily beta
forty and forty two when you look at
control control individuals compared to
those that have Alzheimer's disease that
those levels are higher in heart tissues
similar to how those levels are well
documented to be higher in the brains of
Alzheimer's disease patients so this is
one point to us that we find very
interesting that that shows that other
organs are also having a role in
Alzheimer's disease and then even in our
own lap we've done some studies recently
with proteomics over the years where we
were able to demonstrate that in looking
at liver tissue from an Alzheimer's
disease mouse model we observed higher
levels of proteins involved in beta
oxidation and ketone body formation and
the liver and we believed that these
were showing us that elevated levels of
ketone bodies were being generated in
the liver and possibly traffic to the
brain to compensate for lower levels of
glucose and so these were farther
supported by some metabolomic studies
that redundant demonstrated that in fact
the levels of these small molecules were
higher in the liver tissue okay
so I've given you a lot just in terms of
background about how we think about
Alzheimer's disease in our lab and
really all of that is to show that we
really think that there is a role for
other organs in the periphery in disease
pathogenesis for Alzheimer's disease and
so our lab is really focused on trying
to figure out what the role is for these
different organs and how do these
different systems contribute to racial
and ethnic disparities within
Alzheimer's disease so what I'm going to
do today is to walk you through three
short vignettes
about some of the work that's ongoing in
our lab and I'll start with a study
where we've been looking at the
relationship between the brain and
periphery and mouse models and in human
tissues of Alzheimer's disease
so one might envision that the goal for
this particular project is to really
understand the relationship between the
brain and periphery and so this gives
you an illustration of how we think
about this so if you have different
organs that exists either in a mouse
model or in the human tissue and you
think about a pathway such as metabolism
then you can see that different organs
have different enzymes that might
contribute to the overall metabolism
that's taking place in the body in
addition to the lower levels of
metabolism that are well documented in
Alzheimer's disease so our idea is to
figure out if we start to look very
early on prior to disease onset and at
different stages in all of these
different organs and in the brain can we
really start to figure out system-wide
what are the initiators of these
metabolic changes or other changes that
are taking place in this Alzheimer's
disease system so for this work we've
used in Alzheimer's disease mouse model
system this is a system that is a human
double transgenic Nakia mouse model so
it has human Swedish mutations in
amyloid precursor protein of priests in
l1 and we've collected tissues from this
mouse over the course of 3 7 12 and 14
months and what you notice in this motto
is that as it is odor or disease
progresses more you go from an animal
that is similar to a wild-type at 3
months to an animal that starts to
exhibit early stages of Alzheimer's
disease with sparse Emily deposits in
the brain that in later stages has
numerous amyloid beta deposits so much
as some of the pathology I'm in humans
and so this isn't a fully comprehensive
model of Alzheimer's disease but it is
one that allows us to get some insight
about changes that are taking place as a
disease and the studies aren't going to
talk about we looked at 14 month old
animals
so one of the projects that we have
ongoing is done by graduate students now
postdoc in the group Christina King and
she's interested to understand
system-wide changes in Alzheimer's
disease using a mouse model and so what
we did was we took wild type in our a
PPP s1 which I'll refer to as a AD mouse
model and in each of these models we
were able to harvest liver brain and
heart tissue from each individual animal
and so we ended up with biological
replicates of six for each group and a
total of 36 on samples and so in order
to run these samples using proteome is
in a comprehensive way we decided to
employ a technique that we developed in
the group that relies on quantitative
proteomics so this is a technique that
we develop your set and it's called
combined precursor isotopic labeling and
isobaric tagging and the way the
strategy works is we take tissues that
can come from wild-type and AD animals
so over here on the left part of this
graph we have three pairs of wild-type
and diseased animals we take the tissues
from those harvested proteins and
generate tryptic peptides and to these
tryptic peptide mixtures what we then do
is lower the pH of the buffer and we do
a reductive die methylation reaction
which adds a dye methyl group to the
n-terminal mean of the peptides what
that does is it leaves the lysine amine
open for further chemistry and tagging
so then we use these commercial tandem s
tags in order to label lysine residues
so each of these six individual samples
gets one of the six different kinds of
TMT tags that you can get that generate
these report Iron shown from 126 to 131
M over Z and so we have six unique tags
over here on the Left we do the same
thing with a different set of tissues
and animals over here on the right and
the only difference here is that when we
do the dumbass elation reaction
this time methylation reaction consists
of heavy isotopes and so there's two
carbon 13 and six deuterium and so we
add that tag to the n-terminal amines
and then we're able to use the other
half of a TMT reagent Val to do the
lysine tagging so we're able to save
cost here but also expand the amount of
sample multiplexing that we get
so all in all we take 12 uniquely tagged
samples mix them together and then we do
one comprehensive multi-dimensional
lc/ms experiment where in this case we
might use strong cation exchange coupled
to reverse phase chromatography
an example of what you would see we can
get the data is shown here where in the
four MS kin we would see pairs of Peaks
that are separated by a mass of a
balance for each done methyl group that
we've added so our light and our heavy
pairs with that ms/ms data we require a
selection of the light or the heavy
Peaks independently in order to get
sequence coverage and then we isolate
the most intense or with more advanced
instrumentation the top most intense
ions to then fragment again and generate
ms3 so the most important part of this
experiment is the MS 3 spectra would
give which give us reporter ion data
from each sample and inform us on the
relative concentration of peptides and
proteins and how they're changing across
different conditions okay so we employed
this strategy to Christine a set of
samples and here's an example of the
data that we got from effusions almost
on the left so here you can see an
example peptide that has been
demethylated on an interminable TMT 6
flex reagent on the lysine residue and
if you just look at C then what you can
appreciate is that within this set of
data we can see the difference in level
of this peptide between a wild-type
animal compared to a disease within a
heart tissue a brain or a liver tissue
but then if you look across these
twelve-piece
then we can actually start to see the
differences across biological replicate
and within tissues so we think this is
experiment is pretty powerful we've
taken this data and we ran the samples
on different instrumental platforms as
we had access to better technology so we
started on an orbit Veloz instrument and
you can see we identified about 2,200
proteins we then moved to a fusion
almost instrument and we did this
experiment without any scx fractionation
with incorporating scx fractionation and
you can see with the Lumos we get about
five thousand proteins identified across
the tissues and then here you can see
how these proteins overlap across the
different platforms that we use what's
most interesting to us about on this
kind of data is what happens when you
start to tease apart specific kinds of
pathways so here's an example of what
happens when you look at glycolysis
system-wide so here I'm showing you the
glycolytic pathway and these are the
proteins and enzymes that we've observed
in that pathway using this proteomics
data set and so for example if you look
at glucose 6 phosphate isomerase what
you can see is at the level of this
protein and the alzheimer's disease
brain tissue is lower compared to that
in the wild-type brain similarly the
same is true for the heart tissues where
the levels are lower in the disease
animal compared to the wild type however
in the liver you see I'm a different
behavior where the levels of this enzyme
are higher in the disease animal
compared to the wall type and so you can
look across this on slide at the
different proteins in the pathway and
see how they're changing and what this
does is it gives you a sense of the
overall metabolism is taking place in
the entire animal and not just within
the brain tissue where we mostly focus
on disease pathogenesis and
interestingly what you see is that there
appear to be a lot of things that are
happening in the liver tissue that are
concert with things happening in the
brain in the heart that are most similar
to each other so we have lots of these
kinds of stories when you look at
different kinds of biological pathways
and to further support what we're seeing
with the glycolytic pathway there was a
recent metabolomic study that came out
by xenian coworkers and what this one
shows is that if you look at the
metabolites in this seam ad mouse model
across liver kidney and heart tissues is
that you start to see a lot of
metabolites that are changing and energy
metabolism pathways as well and so what
they identify in their work is that very
early on and the liver tissue you start
to see changes in energy and metabolism
that precede changes that take place in
hard liver and other tissues so we think
this presents a really good way to start
to tease apart what's happening in AD in
early stages and by focusing on tissues
outside of the brain but there are some
caveats to using animal model systems to
fully understand disease pathogenesis
and so while there's a lot that we can
do with animal model systems such as
being able to harvest tissue from
multiple organs being able to use a
smaller number of in and order to get a
bit statistical power being able to do
this in a much faster time than we could
do with human samples and all the tricks
that we can we play with genetics on
there are the cons that sometimes the
things that we find in these model
systems aren't always directly
translated into human studies and that's
because there's so much more diversity
and human systems that aren't accounted
for in a mouse model systems and those
could be things like socioeconomic
geographical other kinds of diversity
and that the systems that we work with
when we get data from humans aren't as
well controlled as what they would be
from a mouse model system so that's led
us to try to explore doing some kinds of
studies in human systems and so here
what we've done is we've done a pilot
where we got some whole body tissues
from a brain bank and air
and Institute and we were able to get
three or three sets of control and three
sets of AD individuals where we could
get the heart brain and frontal gyrus
tissue and liver tissue from these
individuals postmortem so we did a
similar quantitative proteomic studies
in our C palate strategy on these sets
of tissues and we wanted to see how
relevant were the things that we found
in our mouse model to this of human
tissues
what this slide shows you is and the
overlap that we got and proteins that we
identified across the different tissues
so here on the left you can see in our
ad mouse model we see a very substantial
overlap and proteins across different
tissues when we look at the human data
here on their right then you can see
that again we have very consistent
overlap and proteins that we observe
across the tissues which pretty much
means that we get coverage across most
of our reporter ion channels for each
protein but you also see that the number
of proteins that we see is fairly Simar
similar between our mouth and our human
system this is a heat map that gives you
an idea of the kinds of changes that we
see over all across the different
tissues so here on the right is a one
example area where we zoomed in and you
can clearly see from the heat mount that
there are substantial changes that are
taking place in the brain indicated by
the red colors which are more pronounced
than those happening in the heart and
the liver however when you start to look
at differences between the control and
the disease individuals then you can
actually see that there is a lot of
things that are happening in all three
of these different tissues and so to
give you a sense for how we look at the
data this is just pulling out two
proteins
alpha in elacin tubulin aflateen and
which we wouldn't expect much activity
with disease and so here you can see
that the levels are higher for both of
these proteins and the brain tissue
compared to the heart and liver and it
doesn't appear to be much change
happening between the control and the
diseased individuals
so we can keep mining the data in this
way but it's also easier to just kind of
look at an overview of the data and so
these volcano plots give you a sense for
the global changes that we see in each
of the tissues and so what we've done
here is we've aligned the same tissue
from the mouse model with a human brain
tissue
heart to heart and liver liver and so
you can see that there are some
differences that might be observed when
you look at that Mouse compared to the
human system so for example if you look
over here at the liver you can see that
in the mouse model system we see more
proteins that are have higher levels in
the disease animal compared to the wild
type animal whereas in the human system
we see more proteins that have lower
levels in the disease animal or in the
diseased individual compared to the
control individual so we're working
through the data now to figure out how
much similarity or homology there are
and proteins that are different across
disease and within different tissues and
you know can kind of give you a preview
that already what we see is that there
are things that some things that overlap
but a lot of things that are unique to
their mouse model system or the human
system so we definitely want to continue
to do this work and tease out what's
happening but overall what we think
we've been able to demonstrate with
these kinds of studies is that there's a
lot that's happening and other tissues
and other organs and disease and these
are worthwhile investigations because
they can help us better understand the
pathogenesis of Alzheimer's disease but
importantly they also help us understand
what the relationship might be with the
risk factors for Alzheimer's disease
such as the comorbidities that I
mentioned early on
so the second story that I wanted to
tell you about is when where we've been
working over the last couple years to
get some pilot data to really start to
investigate racial disparities that
exist within Alzheimer's disease in us
so these are all preliminary work pilot
studies and so I'll just give you a
sense of what we're doing so what we did
was we work with the Alzheimer's disease
Research Center at the University of
Pittsburgh and the goal was to perform a
small study with tissues that I had
available from african-americans and
non-hispanic whites to understand
whether or not there were molecular
differences and post-mortem brain tissue
and so what we did was we got as many
tissues as occur from an
african-american group that were
cognitively normal and that had a D and
this was diagnoses post-mortem and then
we match to that our non-hispanic white
on participants so our end for this
study are fairly small so for most of
the groups here we have an end of five
and what Caitlyn did in the study was to
look across different brain regions so
here we mostly focused on the
hippocampus which has you know early
changes they take place in 18 we looked
at the inferior parietal lobe portion of
the brain which also has some changes
that have been later in professions and
then we looked at the Globus pallidus
which is a region that doesn't have much
pathology that occurs in AD and we
thought that would serve as a good
negative control for this study and all
of the experiments were randomized and
blinded to Caitlyn when she began to
work
so again we use different EMS platforms
to do these studies where we start on
one platform and then get access to more
say there are instrumentation so we
started this work with an elite MS and
these are just TMT based experiments and
so we had less than 900 proteins that we
identify with that platform we then did
the same MS 3 experiment on a fusion
Lumos and we got up to about 33 34
hundred proteins and then when we just
look at doing ms/ms with the TMT on the
fusion then we see about 550 200
proteins that we've identified so the
platform here definitely influences what
we get from the data and if we just
focus on the portion of proteins we
identify from the hippocampus and
compare that to a comprehensive study
that was reported by peg and all where
they looked at 27 different brain
regions then what you see here is that
we have an overlap of about 2,800
proteins that were previously identified
so that gave us some confidence that we
were seeing things that have been seen
before in AD brain but we also have a
lot of unique proteins that we observe
in our study that weren't reported in
the pengon all study and similar for
them and so we think that every time
these experiments are random we can
learn more about what's happening in the
brain for all of the changes that for
some of the changes that we observe with
the TMT approach and our dataset we went
and did a verification with Western blot
so this shows you some examples for
beta-actin peroxy redox and fatty acid
binding protein and cam k2 alpha where
you're on the changes we saw by CMT with
supported by Western data and then if we
start to look at the hippocampal region
then here we can see from the these
volcano plots how proteins are changing
with disease but importantly how they're
changing with the different racial
backgrounds that we looked at of the
so on the top PC data from the
non-hispanic white population where you
can see um you know there's almost equal
distribution of proteins that are higher
in expression in Alzheimer's disease
compared to cognitively normal
individuals however if you look at the
changes on the bottom that are
demonstrated for the participants that
self-identified as african-americans
you see that we see more emphasis on the
left where there are proteins that are
lower in expression and the Alzheimer's
disease individuals compared to those
that are cognitively normal so this is
the first clue to us that there was
something really interesting happening
here in the data set and you can see
that for a few proteins that we've
labeled there's some things that are
similar so for example the wheel of
raillery acidic protein is one that
seems to be pretty consistent just
within Alzheimer's disease so the next
thing that i want to show you is how
we've taken the proteins that are
different between our Alzheimer's
disease and cognitively normal
individuals and we've looked at them by
racial ethnic group and then also by
brain region so if you focus your
attention just to what's happening in
the hippocampal region then you can see
that we observe less proteins that are
similar between the non-hispanic white
and african-american groups of ESPA 99
then we observe proteins that are unique
to each racial group so these are all
proteins that are changing and the
disease changing with Alzheimer's
disease but are appearing to be more
unique to a racial group we then looked
at different brain regions so the
inferior parietal lobule and the Globus
pallidus regions and we see similar
behavior where there's less numbers of
proteins that are similar between the
two racial groups than there are
proteins that are unique to a racial
group and so I'll be at the end for
this study is small we do think this
points to the fact that there may be a
lot of changes that are taking place in
Alzheimer's disease that we've not been
aware of because of the lack of
diversity in the populations that have
been analyzed so when we focus on just
the some example network that we've
observed in the hippocampus tissue then
here you can see that the pathways that
are unique to each specific racial
ethnic group shown here by the string
networks in red are representing
different pathways so for a non-hispanic
white population the most significant
changes were observed in cell signaling
and endocytosis related pathways whereas
in the African American AD group the
most significant changes were observed
in metabolism and immune response and
inflammatory pathway so this we think is
you know pretty pretty exciting and
we're working diligently to try to get
more in so that we can increase the
statistics of our study
very early on in the talk that we've
looked at without lipid metabolism might
be an important factor in disease
pathogenesis so within the same data set
in the hippocampus we started to look at
changes in lipid metabolism proteins so
here you can see we see more proteins
involved in lipid metabolic pathways
when we use the fusion almost compared
to the elite and then what you see with
these different plots or examples of
proteins that behave similar within a
given pathway so for example if you look
at B what you find with the black trace
in the middle is that on average
proteins in this this pathway behave
very similarly between the non-hispanic
group non-hispanic white group compared
to the african-american group where
these lipid proteins are lower in
Alzheimer's disease compared to
cognitively normal individuals however
this is different for the proteins that
are shown in D where on average these
proteins are higher in expression in the
Alzheimer's disease from non-hispanic
white individuals however aren't
appearing to change in the
african-american group so I think these
kinds of data for us showed us that a
lot of the changes that we may be seeing
in Alzheimer's disease when we look at
the different ethnic group may not
necessarily be really dramatic or
drastic changes so sometimes these
changes are going to be more subtle but
they're still worthwhile to identify
we then looked in a different peripheral
fluid so we looked in a plasma tissue
that came from participants that meet
the demographics that are shown here and
so we started by just randomly selecting
ten individuals from each one of these
groups and getting the pilot going and
this is work by Mustafa Kahn will be
finishing in the next year in the group
and what he's done is he also did a TMT
based proteomics experiment and you can
see here how many proteins he identifies
across each patch so in total we were
able to look at 24 52 plasma proteins
and see how they changed across the
different groups this gives you a sense
for the reproducibility across the
different batches that he ran so he was
getting very similar reported ion
intensity across them and most
surprising to us is that when we started
to look at proteins that were different
between the ethnic groups that his data
and plasma were very similar to what we
were seeing and the post-mortem brain
tissue where there were few numbers of
proteins that were similar between the
non-hispanic white and african-american
group compared to those that were unique
to the different racial groups and you
can see from the different on pathways
that are represented here by those
proteins that the differences in the
pathways that are driving on those
unique observations between the given
racial groups so we're really excited
about this work it's an ongoing project
that we're working on and so we hope to
share more in the coming months
by way of publication with these
datasets
okay so our primary focus in the lab so
far has been using proteomics techniques
to understand what's happening in
disease pathogenesis with different
models and different individuals that
come from different racial ethnic
backgrounds so I thought I finished by
sharing a last and short vignette that
has to do with the work that we're doing
to develop lipid omec strategies to
complement the work that we're doing
with the proteomics for these kinds of
applications so for these studies we've
been working on establishing a lipid
omics platform to study lipids from
human plasma and so right now we have
worked out a sample preparation method
that takes advantage of Bligh Dyer where
we get our extracted lipids and then we
can take these lipids after we spike in
an internal standard and we expose them
to three different kinds of strategies
so the first strategy is an untargeted
lipid omics strategy using a thermo two
executive instrument the second strategy
is one that uses multiple reaction
monitoring on a sigh x.q trap instrument
that targets about 1200 different plasma
lipids that have been validated and then
the last platform is one that was a
single reaction monitoring on a TS q
quantum Ultra instrument where we just
focused on lip is involved in the
cholesterol pathway and all of these are
subject to different kinds of data now
assists and bio statistical approaches
and this just gives you a sense for the
chromatography instruments and mass spec
instruments that are used for these
studies so we start by spiking our
mixtures with the internal standard mix
that comes from Avanti this mix has a
good distribution of different kinds of
lipid classes and also good distribution
of concentrations of these lipids that
show up and so these are deuterated
forms of
the lipids and for each sample that we
analyze we do two injections so one to
give positive ionization mode data and a
second and get negative ionization mode
data and so these are data that I'm
showing you for the untargeted platform
on the QE HF and you can see that we see
a good distribution of lipids across the
different classes and so you can better
see that when we look at these pie chart
distributions of lipids across different
lipid classes and so mostly what you see
is that in both positive and negative
ionization mode we have about half of
the lipids that we see our
glycerophospholipids and then we see a
large percentage of lipids that are fat
ESL's and also a glycerol lipids and
stir all lipids that are also observed
so we do get some better performance of
ionization for different lipids and the
negative ionization modes and positive
so for example phosphatidyl inositol are
better ionized and negative ionization
mode than what we see here in the
positive ionization mode data so we took
a small subset of lipid samples from
mustapha's plasma cohort and we just had
five cognitively normal individuals and
580 individuals and we subjected them to
reproducible experiments that we ran on
three different days and so these are
not batch corrected so that you can see
the differences between the patches and
so easy from the PCA plot so that we can
distinguish between the cognitively
normal individuals from the disease
individuals very clearly and then you
can also see that there's there
differences between the days and so
those things are being normalized and
then what you see here on the right is
that we see differences and the lipids
that we observe between our Alzheimer's
disease compared to our conductivity
cognitively normal individuals so we
look at these valid class and that's
represented here on this bar chart where
you can go across the different classes
that we observed in the untargeted
analysis and for most of the classes we
see changes that are consistent with
what's reported in the literature so for
example the first column is the
phosphatidylcholine
and those are lower and expression in
Alzheimer's disease and so that's what
we see is consistent with that but then
you see other pathways such as the lyso
phosphatidyl ethanolamine that are
higher in expression in the Alzheimer's
disease compared to the cognitively
normal individuals so we're working on
again getting more into beef up these
data but these just gave us a sense that
we could begin to do these analysis with
this untargeted platform you can always
mine the data farther to go in and look
at an individual lipid species of
interest and so here you can see many of
those where you can start to tease apart
how they're changing with the disease
so we worked a lot on the untargeted
platform and then we were able to
establish a partnership with sai X where
we could look at targeted lipids and so
here with their platform they have 1250
lipids that they know exist in plasma
and that have been tested and so here
what you see on the top is an example
trace using hillock that shows you the
separation of the different lipid
classes that have all been labeled
pretty clearly and then what's
impressive about what you see on the
bottom is that we've taken our 30
different samples so these were the
different days of batches of samples
that we had and ran them after each
other non-stop and you can see just how
reproducible the chromatography is for
these particular species you can go into
any specific point in time here on the
chromatogram and then you can get back
an annotated spectrum from the platform
so here you can see for the phosphate
phosphatidyl ethanolamine Peaks that
have been identified previously using
this data and so we can get that kind of
information for each flipping class and
right now we're just really trying to
learn how to handle these data and work
through them but we're really excited
about the quality of video that we're
getting from both platforms and even
though I'm not showing you that we do
have some data that support we see
similar changes with the targeted
platform as we do with the untargeted
platform and then if you want to go in
and further mine a specific pathway and
the metabolism here we were able to
follow cholesterol and its precursors
and a specific pathway using a very
targeted SRM approach and so here down
the left you can see the different
cholesterol and precursor species that
we've looked at the transitions that
have been identified by mass-to-charge
and then you can see how robust the
chromatography is for identifying these
particular species with this essay so
this is been in collaboration with the
colleague here at Vanderbilt net Porter
and for these studies the only species
in the South way that we observed a
difference for was cholesterol between
the cognitively normal and a diseased
individual okay so thank you for hanging
in there with me over the course of the
last 45 minutes or so I hope what I've
been able to show you are a lot of the
different kinds of projects that we're
working on in the lab I hope importantly
we've been able to show you how enhanced
multiplexing with proteomics is very
useful for giving us the ability to
study Alzheimer's disease using
different tissues and the periphery and
in the frame looking across different
disease stages in a way that we believe
is very high throughput and
cost-effective I also hope that we've
shown you just how dynamic the changes
are that we see in energy and listen
metabolism pathways as well as others
when you start looking at heart and
liver alongside the brain and this is
true for both our 80 mouse model and
human tissues that we have served and I
showed you some interesting data that is
very preliminary looking at racial
ethnic differences and AD and what we
observe in post-mortem brain and in
plasma are that there are differences
that exist and so we're still trying to
get more statistics to better understand
what these differences are so we think
they're important to helping us think
about one understanding disease
pathogenesis but also begin to think
about how treatments should be
established for Alzheimer's disease and
personalized medical kinds of ways and
then I hope that I've shown you some of
the fun that we've been having learning
about lipid omics and trying to develop
strategies there that we believe can
help complement the work that
doing the proteomics all of the work
that we that we've done and that I've
talked about was all made possible with
mass spectrometry and different kinds of
mass spec platforms I'd like to thank my
team who has contributed significantly
to the work that we've done our
collaborators at the University of
Pittsburgh and also here at Vanderbilt
that have helped to support the work
that we've done with lipid omics
development and then I'd like to thank
our funding agencies Banner Health for
helping with the sample providing
samples for the human tissue work I like
to thank excellent for sponsoring this
session and again thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to answer any
question
Thank You Rene for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Rene will answer as many
questions as time permits okay let's get
started
our first question is why do you think
the overlap in protein identification
from the various MS platforms to use for
the mouth work was low compared to all
of the proteins identified that's a good
question so what we've learned
every time that we run these experiments
is that we don't always see the same
things I'll be if we do see a good
number of the same thing so I think a
lot of it has to do with some subtle
differences in the way that we carried
out the fractionation as we evolved over
the years from the vivos platform to the
MS I also think a lot has to do with the
sampling of how the data are sampled in
the mass spec from the bellows to the
fusion so what's very critical about
these experiments is that we really have
to observe and isolate both our light
and our heavy precursors in order to get
back robust reporter ion data and so in
that I think if only a single payer was
to let a single peak of the pair was
selected in the Veloz platform or in the
fusion then we wouldn't have as much
overlap between the techniques and so
certainly we've observed it with the
Lumos were able to increase our sampling
of light and heavy pairs and so we get
more comprehensive data with that
platform
thank you do you see all lipid classes
with salty untargeted and targeted MS
approaches so no so we don't see all
lipid classes I do think we see a
majority of the lipid classes that are
observed
I think the platform itself with most
influences our ability to see the lipid
classes are the front end separations
that are used so in a way that we've
been working on this we ended up
switching from a reverse phase
separation that we were using for the
untargeted to a hillock base separation
for the targeted and we found that the
hell it gave us more robust coverage are
the different kinds of lipids but there
were a couple of classes that we still
didn't observe with the hillock
separation either and a targeted
platform and so I think you know there's
specific classes that you want to go
after definitely doing a more targeted
separation approach to get them is going
to be necessary
Nicole is the MS platform to the quality
of the data presented for the proteomics
work oh this is very critical oh they
have been I was forthcoming and the data
that we showed throughout I'm just
showing the evolution of the quality of
the data that we got from Veloz and
Elite platforms compared to fusion
almost platforms
I think the massive trying to place a
big role because the performance of them
aspect by way of sensitivity and duty
cycle and how fast you can generate
different hands is very critical to
being able to get as much data as you
can but also as much data of good
quality so certainly we've observed you
know with with better instruments in
time we've been able to get better
quality i'm data i will say that i don't
think that you know so we have to have
some of the best instruments to get
quality data i think it just requires
more work on the front end and in the
way that you do your data collection in
order to get comparable amount of
information but yeah hopefully that
answers you know answer the questions
definitely with with better quality
instruments we get better data overall
whether that was with our proteomics i
workflow or with our lipid omics
workflow as well
thank you okay it looks like we have
time for one more question
have you considered ways to increase the
sample size for ethnic groups ethnic
groups and also to look across other
racial ethnic groups
yes so yeah we certainly were naive only
went into this project and thought it
would be very easy to get the large
sample sizes for different ethnic groups
and we realize that you know that would
require more work but we've been working
diligently to establish collaborations
with groups in the u.s. that has cohorts
where they look at african-american
groups so that we can increase our
sample in there and we've been
interested to also look at other racial
groups I think that will come with top
with time once we can build up on these
collaborations to have access to samples
and also once we can demonstrate that we
have a good handle on what in is
necessary to get good quality data
that's going to be you know powered well
statistically but also start to learn
what the differences are but I
definitely think you know in the future
we have to look across different ethnic
groups and I will say racial and ethnic
groups so that we can have a good
understanding of what's happening with
disease because for example you know
Japanese Americans have extremely lower
prevalence of Alzheimer's disease
compared to other groups and so I think
you know that's interesting to follow up
in study as well
you
I would like to once again thanks to
thank Renee for her presentation I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and further interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed at a speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank labyrinth and our sponsor
Agilent for underwriting today's
educational webcast lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye